you seem like you're very good host on
that show - you feel like you'd be a
good talk-show host you ever think about
this kind of thing there's no you know
I'm just not interested
I think they cheered you before they
heard your answer I'm not really
interested in people at all someone if I
were my first guest that would be fun or
if you were on my show or you were on my
job that would be fun but I feel for you
when you have the guy who's the number
one when number one on the call sheet of
the CBS crime procedural and you've got
to drag his ass through a stupid story
about what happened to him at the car
wash that day and I I just I couldn't do
that I don't know how you do it
it's a card you're about to knock it
over exactly just curious what happened
you at the car wash I gotta ask you one
question you are so funny playing many
parts but I have noticed you are
particularly good at playing very
sexually confident people and I see you
do it I mean the first time I saw you do
it was in 40 year old virgin where
you're just the most sexually confident
[Applause]
is this at all reflect who Jane Lynch
might be not at all I just people who
are sexually and confident and it's
completely unearned make me laugh yes
you know they kind of walk into a room
it's like the drunk people - that pause
a little longer and take a long that
that makes me laugh though those know my
favorite thing to do is walk into a room
full of beautiful women and be like
sorry ladies take it it's not gonna
happen and they're all like we could
care
that makes me laugh I love it hey good
luck to you at the Emmys well thank you
yes graduations the creative Emmys which
is the what they call the children's
table Emmys we're the weekend before but
you can watch it on FXX it's like not
even FX is FXX right but hey watch it
and see what happens
it was the worst pitch of all time it's
on FXX
ass ass I don't even know what happens
to watch it if you want my nine hours on
you